pas quand même pas briser en six mois
une histoire de deux semaines
et maintenant j'accueille Gaspard Proust
pour l'été de Gaspard
[Applaudissements]
c'est les vacances
je viens de me faire lourder
l'avion moi j'ai eu la chance de pas
finir attacher un arbre au bord du
périph donc c'est déjà ça et tout ça
pour qui quoi un type juste parce que
soi-disant c'était son mari
45 ans une femme ça doit penser à son
avenir un avenir à 45 ans
l'immaturité des cadra génère
moi je lui ai dit que c'est escassait je
m'ouvrais les veines puis finalement non
quand j'ai trop peur de choper le
tétanos
impulsif immature gamorbe sur le but de
la vie c'est de ressembler à Edouard
Balladur pour arrêter
enfin bref j'en profitais là pour lancer
un SOS amoureux
SOS d'un que tu as en détresse
ma chérie mon cœur
trop froid faudrait un truc entre les
deux espèce de [ __ ]
tu as décidé de me quitter j'aurais aimé
la prendre autrement que par un statut
facebook likez 450 fois et qui disait je
ne suis plus en couple mais l'autre con
n'est pas encore au courant lol
et ma mère qui fait le premier
commentaire je suis content pour toi
n'oublie pas de vite aller faire des
tests au labo
malgré tout je ne cesse de penser à toi
Lamartine disait un seul être vous
manque et tout était peuplé [ __ ] comme
il avait raison quoi puis que tu es
parti je me rends compte que tu étais la
seule personne que je connaissais
alors tu me reproches d'être possessive
jaloux ça a quand même pas être de ma
faute si j'étais toujours trouvé sublime
dans cette robe noire que je t'ai ramené
de Kaboul quoi je veux dire
tu te souviens quand je te disais fous
ta cagoule
qu'est-ce qu'on réel enfin je dis ça je
pouvais pas voir son visage
[Applaudissements]
tu trouvais que j'étais radin quel à
gratitude c'est qui qui a ouvert une
tortue à l'ouvre-boite dans le jardin
des plantes pour faire les lunettes en
écailles à 15000 balles
elle s'appelait Audrey aussi j'avais un
truc avec je sais pas moi allez reviens
quoi tu vas bien que je pars à la dérive
je me ridiculise devant
pas quand même pas briser en six mois
une histoire de deux semaines
alors ok ok comme dans tous les coups
pour la connu des bons et des mauvais
moments souviens de la foi ou la capote
a craqué que trois mois plus tard à
l'hôpital je filmais ta fausse couche
mais c'est vrai qu'on a aussi connu des
moments pénibles
comme la fois où j'ai débarqué à
l'improviste tu prenais un bain et que
pour te faire rire j'ai jeté un
sèche-cheveux branché dans la mousse
je peux pas savoir moi c'est ta mère qui
était dans le bain quoi
façon à laver une maladie incurable la
ménopause
[Rires]
j'oublierai jamais ton regard après la
soirée passée en boîte chez Régine en
train de faire l'amour sur le capot de
la voiture
j'aurais tellement aimé que ce soit moi
[Applaudissements]
enfin je sais pas mais ce que je te
raconte j'espère que tu auras la
lucidité de reconnaître la grave erreur
que tu es en train de commettre parce
que des mecs comme moi tu en trouveras
pas souvent quoi une fois on faisait
l'amour elle m'a dit le sexe c'est mieux
avec les sentiments je dis bah écoute
c'est pas grave pense à ton ex si tu
préfères
je suis une perle et j'espère que ça te
ronge PS combien de fois j'aurais pu te
tromper mais j'avais pas assez de fric
sur moi
je dis vachement bien traité quoi je
découvre la passivité de toute façon
quand on pense que 90 % des femmes sont
clitoridières à quoi bon s'acharner
aborder
alors et pas beau l'été
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu